Joe Biden likely had a lot on his mind
just a few hours before meeting with
Kevin McCarthy while Joe's beloved
multi-million dollar beach house in
Rehoboth Delaware it was finally
searched by the FBI now this comes three
entire months after stolen classified
documents turned up at the UPenn Biden
Center remember that was six days before
the midterms on November the 2nd and two
months after more classified material
was located in the garage with that
Corvette right there the safe garage
that he says is locked all the time that
obviously is not locked all the time and
by the way at five separate locations
within these homes and and offices now
two weeks after even more classified
material was discovered during a search
at Biden's home in Wilmington Delaware
and 10 days after Joe made a very
unusual winter trip to his Rehoboth
Beach House this was in January now
think about this Joe Biden took a trip
to his beach house in January I'm sure
it was beautiful I'm sure the weather
was crappy but 10 days before the FBI
searched that very property for
classified documents so what was Joe
doing there remember this is during an
ongoing criminal investigation and Joe
Biden is the subject of that
investigation and yet the FBI's what
perfectly fine with Biden spending a few
days at the location that they should be
searching should have searched already
and are going to search you think they
would have that given that same
opportunity to Donald J Trump I doubt it
now they rated Mar-A-Lago Before Dawn
without warning even though Donald Trump
was cooperating with their requests now
we're watching a two-tiered system of
justice play out in real time in this
country so equal justice under the law
equal application of our laws sadly does
not exist any longer with the Biden doj
now still today some Democrats they were
seized by federal agents in Rehoboth but
we don't know if any of the material was
classified or any other documents were
moved or destroyed before the FBI
conducted their search while Joe was
vacationing on the beach in January now
keep in mind this is the third Biden
property that was searched by the FBI
that we know of we do know of two more
locations that need to be searched one
would be Hunter Biden's house and the
other would be the University of
Delaware we'll have more on that in a
minute but of course the White House
Council is refusing to tell any of us if
the other locations were visited by the
FBI take a look
just to be very clear has the FBI
conducted any searches of any other
locations associated with the president
that you or the White House is aware of
look I think we're providing information
as this goes on and answering questions
about the the search activities as
they've been happening I don't want to
speak too much to the doj's practices in
an ongoing investigation
simple question did they search the
house or not that's a yes or a no no in
between well you saw there that's called
spin that's called not answering the
question now the White House is also
refusing to tell us how many classified
documents have been recovered take a
look at this
green what is the current number of
documents varying classified markings
that have been found in the president's
presidency
office refer you to the way council's
office Ian just declined to comment on
them
now the White House has reportedly
blocked the national archives from
updating you the American people on this
case now that's something that Biden's
team will neither confirm nor deny take
a look at this there's reporting that
came from the house oversight committee
chairman James Comer who says that in
his conversations with the National
Archives they communicated that they
were told the archives was told it could
not release a press release
at whatever point it was about the
discovery of classified documents and
anyone at the White House tell them not
to do yeah I don't know anything about
that if that's actually what he said
it's probably better to ask the archive
oh okay meanwhile who told them not to
answer the question James Comer said
that on this show last night now this is
a cover-up in the making but your FBI
director Christopher Wray your AG mayor
Garland they don't seem to care they
have clearly politicized and weaponized
the Department of Justice in this great
country that is not good for America now
keep in mind most of Biden's documents
from his four decades in office they are
stored at the University of Delaware how
big a trove of documents well we're
talking about 33 pallets of papers
delivered in 2011 not in one truck but
two trucks including over 1800 cartons
of documents and get this a whopping 415
gigabytes of electronic records now
neither Joe Biden or the University of
Delaware will allow anybody to view
those documents University is pretending
that they are still organizing the
material 11 years later but as far as we
know there has been no FBI search at the
University of Delaware there needs to be
one or for that matter Hunter Biden's
house and office there needs to be one
and according to the New York Post
remember this broke over the weekend
Hunter offered to sell intelligence so
seemingly what looked like intelligence
according to officials on Russian
oligarchs to the U.S aluminum firm Alcoa
for fifty five thousand dollars where
did Hunter get information on Russian
oligarchs we need an answer to that
question and given Hunters deep ties to
China Russia Ukraine not to mention the
crack cocaine the prostitutes you would
think that the FBI and the doj would
want to make sure that there's no
classified documents in Hunter's
possession after all he was in the very
house where classified documents were
found but again to the best of our
knowledge Hunter's house has not been
raided why not what's really going on
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis us you will not get
it anywhere else